اعلم رئيس هيئه العليا للانتخابات فاروق
بوعسكر بلوغه نسبه الاقبال على التصويت في
الانتخابات التشريعيه التونسيه ثمانيه
وثمانيه اعشار في المئه وفيما وصف ابو
عسكر نسبه الاقبال بالمتواضعه لكنها لا
تدعو للخجل اكدت المعارضه التونسيه ان
اعجاب تونسيين عن التصويت نزع الشرعيه عن
الرئيس سعيد الداعيه الى الانتخابات
الرئاسيه مبكرا للخروج من الازرق
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مصارعه كيف نفهم المشاركه
الضعيفه في الانتخابات التشريعيه التونسيه
وما رسائل الشارع من مقاطعتها وهل جاءت
استجابه لنداءات القوه السياسيه ام اعتراض
على المنظومه برمتها ثم نتساءل عن النتائج
المترتبه عن هذه الانتخابات وكيف سيتم
التعامل مع البرلمان الذي افرزته قالو ليا
وسياسيا ثم نبحثه في الانعكاسات المعتمله
للوضع السياسي الرهيلي على الاقتصاد
التونسي في ضوء تعليقي مفاوضات صندوق
النقد وباي اي عين تنظر القوه الاقليميه
والدوليه للوضع ما بعد الانتقالات
[موسيقى]
استوقفت نسبه المشاركه في الانتخابات
التشريعيه التي شهدتها تونس جميع الاطراف
ذات الصله من قريب او بعيد بالازمه
المتفقين في البلاد استحقاقه انتخابي ام
بنى على اساس الدستور والمراسيم والقرارات
التي وضعها وفردها الرئيس قيس سعيد
وشكل بنتائج التي اسفر عنها في نظري
كثيرين محطه الاخرى لاختبار بدا شعبيه
مسار الخامس والعشرين من يوليو ومات له من
سياساته المعارضون لسعيد وحتى كثير من من
يسندونه سلمه بنسبه الاقبال الضعيفه وغير
المسبقه على التصويت وان اختلفوا في تحديد
اسباب ذلك ليبقى السؤال عما ينتظر المشهد
السياسي في تونس في الايام القادمه رئيس
الهيئه العليا للانتخابات فاروق بو عسكر
رجح امكانيه تنظيم دوره ثانيه للانتخابات
في اكثر من 100 دائره من اجماليه 161
دائره انتخابيه علم وان نسبه التصويت
المسجله تعد الاضعف على امتداد ثمانيه
استحقاقات انتخابيه منذ الثوره
ومن جانبه قال رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطني
احمد نجيب الشاب ان الجبهه تعتقد ان نسبه
التصويت في الانتخابات لم تتجاوز اثنين في
المئه وانه منذ اليوم فقد الرئيس قيس سعيد
شرعيته واكد شاب عزم الجبهه العمل على عزل
الرئيس واجراء انتخابات رئاسيه مبكرا
نحن نطلب ان يرحل من الموقع الذي يحتمله
بغير حق وعلى غير وجه شرعي
بان يتولى هذا المنصب
لفتره انتقاليه وجيزه
كاظم الساهر من كبار القضاه المعروفين
بالاستقامه
والمعروفين بالنزاهه
وبالاستقلاليه ليدير
انتخابات الرئاسيه النافذه
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من تونس جوهر
بن مبارك في جبهه الخلاص الوطني
تونس قيصر السياح المحامي والباحث في
القانون اهلا بكم
سيد قيصر معك اقرا بشكل سريع هذه النسبه
في المشاركه والتي اثارت الكثير من ردود
الفعل بسبب تدليها كيف وجدتها وما تفسير
هذا الانخفاض في نسبه المشاركه
نعم مساء الخير ازيك
اولا هذا العزوف الذي تسلط على الانتخابات
الحاليه البرلمانيه ليس بالجديد فقد سبقه
في محطات سابقه ووزوف كبير في المحطات
الانتخابيه لسنه 2014 و2019 ولم يبلغ حتى
حدث ثلث من الحجم الانتخابي للشعب التونسي
بسناديق الاقتراع رغم اننا كنا في اثار
زخم فوري وخروج من ثوره الى اخره وبالتالي
عزوف هذا كانت له تقاليد تسببت فيها يعني
همم احداث سياسيه معينه وساهم فيها بشكل
كبير الطيف سياسي وان يقبل السياسيه نتيجه
ما تسلط على المشهد السياسي من ابتدال ومن
يعني سيطرت وتغول بعض الاحزاب في المشهد
السياسي والبرلماني ثانيا همم بالنسبه لا
استطيع ان اقول انها ضعيفه باعتبار انها
مرتين كذلك الى حد ما بالدور الثاني الذين
اقل من نوع 161 وهذا العزوز سببه الرئيسي
كما ارى واحلل الان له ثلاث اسباب رئيسيه
على الاقل السبب الاول في هذا العزوف وان
المواطن التونسي اولا جه المشهد السياسي
منذ سنه 2019 عندما راينا المشهد في ذلك
الشكل وسله الدماء
على المشهد السياسي الابتزاز والمناكفات
والمحافظات سياسيه وادى ذلك الحاله الاله
نفور الناس
وغروبهم من المشهد السياسي والانتخابي
المواطن التونسي الوحيد وهم الوحيد
والخروج من هذه القناه اقتصادي والاجتماعي
الصعب الذي يمر سنه 2018
نعم السبب الثالث
هو الرئيسي ان التقليد الجديد للانتخابات
دول الديمقراطيه في العالم من مجموعه 21
دوله ديمقراطيه وهو تقليد بريطاني امريكي
بدرجه اولى
ايضا هذا التقليد لم يقوم متعود عليه
المواطن تونسي
واخيرا المده الزمنيه لم تخول الناخب
التونسي من يوم 30 اكتوبر الى يوم الامس
شهر 17 يوم طيب
ما تراه من اسباب في هذه النسبه في قراءه
هذه وانا اسال ضيفي من تونس السيد جوهر بن
مبارك ايضا عن
كيف يرى هذه النسبه وعلتها
في الحقيقه هي نسبه تاريخيه
ويعني رقم قياسي عالمي في مقاطعه الشعوب
للانتخابات يعني تقريبا وانا مطلع احسب
اني مطلع على الحياه السياسيه في كثير من
دول العالم لم نرى مثل هذه النسب سابقا في
الانتخابات طبعا هناك من سيخرج ليبرر
راينا البارحه رئيس هيئه الانتخابات يبرر
هذه النسبه الضعيفه همم والمهزله
بكون ان هذه الانتخابات لم يدور فيها
المال السياسي ولم يتم شراء همم
وهذا كان فيه وشعره التونسيون بان هذا
تصريح فيه اهانه كبيره لشعب تونس لانه
اعتبر ان تقريبا 92% من الجسم الانتخابي
هو جسم مرتشي وكان يتحرك
بالمال السياسي وهذا امر
غريب وفيه اهانه كبيره للشعب التونسي
ثانيا اريد ان اصحح ان هذه الانتخابات
كانت بعيده جدا على نسب المشاركه في
الانتخابات السابقه الارقام الصحيحه
هي انه في انتخابات 2011 كانت نسبه
المشاركه فقط 62% في الانتخابات 2011
58% وفي نعم وفي انتخابات 2014 فقط 58%
وفي انتخابات 2019 كانت في حدود 52% الان
سقطنا الى 8% يعني ال- ال- الفرق والبون
شاسع المساله لا تتعلق لا يمكن تفسيرها
بالعزوف الانتخابي العادي والتقليدي الذي
تعرفه كل الانتخابات المساله فيها موقف
جديد نحن قرانا في هذه
المقاطعه الشديده والعامه والشامله همم
رسائل سياسيه مهمه ارسل لها شعب تونسي
اولها رساله الى المنقلب بانه همم بان
تونس وشعبها ليسوا منخرطين ابدا وان
اسطوره تحقيق الاراده الشعبيه والحديث
باسم الاراده الشعبيه هي مجرد اسطوره
الرساله الثانيه وجهها شعب التونسي الى
الدوله واجهزه الدوله بان هذا المسار الذي
اختاره قيس سعيد ليس مسار الشعب التونسي
وليس وليس هناك همم انخراط الشعب التونسي
في هذا المسار الرساله الثالثه هي رساله
للطبقه اس- نعم
الرساله الثالثه كانت لي الطبقه السياسيه
الطبقه السياسيه المعارضه بان الان تتحرك
بشكل كبير لتؤثر عمليه رفض شعبي بعد ان
كان هناك رفض سياسي مدني حزبي لمسار قيس
سعيد الان هناك بالارقام بصناديق اقتراع
وضعها قيس سعيد بشروطه ان الشعب غير منخرط
في هذه العمليه
الصياح او لم ياتي الرئيس قيس سعيد ويقوم
بكل هذه الاجراءات حتى كما قال يصحح
انحراف مسار سياسي بعد هذه الفتره عندما
يستفتى الشعب التونسي وتكون النتيجه بهذه
الطريقه ما الذي اختلف اذا
اولا رئيس قيس سعيد هو رئيس الدوله هبه من
احبه اليمن تراه ورمز للدوله ورئيس
الجمهوريه التمد مشروع
لمن هذا الكلام
هذا الكلام
موجه الى المعارضه لاننا اولا في اثار
التحليل السياسي يجب ان ان ان ان نتفق
اولا على ان الدوله لها رمز يسيرها اخطا
او كانت له هناك او كانت هناك اخرلات
قانون الانتخابي او على مستوى المحطه
والمسار هذا امر عليجه بطريقه سلسه فيها
المعارضه وفي السلطه الى اخره اما اننا من
في الدوله
ونجعل من الرئيس الذي تم انتخابه بثلاث
ملاهي مباشره
بلغت اهو 70% ونجعل من مشروعيته التي خروج
الناس ورايتهم
اعذرني عن المقاطعه لم تجيبني على سؤال
اذا كانت هذه الانتخابات في النهايه تقييم
لاداء رئيس جاء واتخذ مجموعه من الاجراءات
كما قال ليصحح مسار سياسيا ثم تاتي
النتائج بهذه الطريقه ويمكن الشعب والشعب
يعزف بهذه الطريقه وبالتالي ما الذي يمكن
قوله امام هذا المشهد
نعم الشعب عندما راينا نسبه الانتخابات
التي صدرت الامس على الاقل في نتائج اوليه
الشعب وانا وعارض السيد جوهر في هذا
التوجه
ليبرر هذه العمليه من انها منطلق فشل بريع
لسياسه السلطه وعلى راسه قيس سعيد وانما
اعتبرته انا شخصيا معاقبه لكل الطيف
السياسي ويحتمل بما فيها السلطه
بدرجه اولى ان النظام الانتخابي هذا عن
الافراد هو انت نظام جديد وليس من
التقاليد التي تعودنا عليها في انتخابات
اثرت على القوائم والتي ادت كما راينا الى
خلالات كبير على مستوى المشهد سياسي في ست
سنوات
فقط حتى يوزع الوقت بشكل
جوهر بن مبارك فيما يتعلق بنقطه اساسيه
اشارنها السيد قيصر السياح بالاشاره الى
اذا ما قرا هذا الموقف وهذا العزوف بانه
رساله موجهه لاداء رئيس سعيد لما لا يكون
هو موقف موجه لكل الطبقه السياسيه برمتها
في تونس حصاد كل هذه السنوات الماضيه بان
الشعب قد مل
المساله بسيطه لانه اغلب الطيف السياسي
والمشهد السياسي ليسوا في الحكم الان في
في المعارضه والشعب لما
يعني يدخل في عمليه انتخابيه تقاطعها
المعارضه ولا تشارك فيها ولا تترشح فيها
وليست طرفا فيها هو يوجه رساله لمن نظم
هذه الانتخابات لمن اثر هذه الانتخابات
لمن طلب هذه الانتخابات لمن نظم هذه
الانتخابات لمن ترشح لهذه الانتخابات كيف
يمكن ان يواجه الشعب التونسي رساله الى
معارضه مقاطعه للانتخابات غير مشاركه فيها
رافضه لها مثلا همم يجب ان ان يعني ان
نعود الى الحد الادنى من العقلانيه
الرساله كانت واضحه والتبريرات الان هي
سقوط فقط لا اكثر ولا اقل سقوط سياسي
محاوله لتبرير واقع ورساله واضحه ارسلها
شعب تونسي بان اسطوره التفويض الشعبي
ان اسطوره المشروعيه الشعبيه التي برر بها
قيس سعيد انقلابه على الشرعيه الدستوريه
والقانونيه بان الشعب التونسي همم هذه
اراده الشعب التونسي الشعب التونسي
بصناديق الاقتراع اولا في الاستشاره
الالكترونيه كانت هناك مؤشرات اوليه ومنذ
عام تقريبا بان الشعب التونسي مقاطع لهذه
العمليه ثم جاء بعد ذلك الحوار الوطني
الذي قطعته تقريبا كل الاحزاب السياسيه
والمنظمات الوطنيه والشخصيات وشاركت فيه
شخصيات ضعيفه
سياسيه هامشيه ثم جاء بعد ذلك الاستفتاء
على الدستور
وراينا كيف ان الشعب التونسي ايضا قاطع
باكثر من 70% استفتاء ان دستوريا كان من
المفترض ان تكون فيه نسبه المشاركه عاليه
الان في هذه الاخير واذا مثلا واعدوننا
المقاطعه ايضا اذا ما سلمنا بما ذكرته
الان هنا اسال ضيف يا سيد قيصر الصياح كيف
تجد ردود فعل الطبقه السياسيه سواء
المعارضه او حتى بعض الاصوات التي كانت
مؤيده لرئيس قيس سعيد نتائج هذا التصويت
وهذا الاقتراع تجاوزت مساله نسبه المشاركه
ولكن الى دعوه لان يغادر قيس هيئه قصر
قرطاج اي دعوه الى تنحي الرئيس قيس سعيد
كيف وجدت هذه الدعوه هذه النتيجه وهذه
خلاص
ادي خلاصه المعارضه فقط المعارضه بطبيعه
الجزء الذي يتجاوزها من المشهد السياسي
ويضروريه لكل انتقال الديمقراطي بالعالم
ونحن الوسام للمعارضه عندما تكون معارضه
ايجابيه بنائه المعارضه لم تقم بلم شملها
ولم تستطع ولم تطرح البدائن ولم تتوحد ولم
تملا حتى الشارع ولم تكسبه الى حد الان
لمده سنه ونصف زياده فتره الكورونا
والجائحه الان ست احزان من بينها يعني
حركه الشعب ومن بين طير الشعبي ولا هو قتل
بالبرلمان هو مهم جدا
وتونس الى الامام وعده احذيه اخرى وشخصيات
سياسيه وعميد المحامين السابق كلهم من
خالته في هذا المسار ولم يعرض هو احد
يشارك في هذه الانتخابات في شكل المباشر
او غير مباشر ويتواجد على سياسي
مسار يوليو 25 يوليو مسار 25 يوليو استمد
منه المشروعيه حيث يستمد مشروعيته وشرعته
من الانتخابات الرئاسيه في ثلاثه ملايين
تونسي 25 يقولوا سيد قيصر الجمله 25 يوليو
حرام 25 همم يونيو دعى الى انتخابات
الرئاسيه مبكرا
وهو مساعد للرئيس
الرئيس قيصر
بانتخابات رئاسيه مبكره والانتخابات
الرئاسيه مبكره وعنوان لتطور لمشهد
الديمقراطي وليس عكسه ولكنه صابر الاراضي
شهر عود بنسبه 69% همم من الناس يؤيدون
تواجهوات ايضا منذ ثلاثه اشهر لاعتقدوا ان
قيس سعيد يتنحى من السلطه بمجرد ذره قلم
من المعارضه التي ليس لها سلطه في عزل
الرؤساء وتعيين القران يحل محل والرئيس
الشعب اما بالشارع او يعذبه بانتخابات
رئاسيه شفافه عندما تنتهي مده النيابيه له
الشعب
مهمه
هذه ايضا نقطه مهمه اسال عنها ضيف يا سيد
جوهر من مبارك الصلاحيه كلها تقريبا في يد
الرئيس سعيد من خلال ما هو معروف من خلال
المسار في الاشهر الماضيه الى حد ما شخصيه
الرئيس قيس سعيد معروفه وبالتالي هذه
الدعوات والحديث عن نتائج هذا الاقتراع
انما هي استفتاء على بقاء قيس سعيد في
كرسي الرئاسه وبالتالي ماذا عن المرحله
القادمه في تونس في ظل هذه الصوره المشوشه
والغامضه
نعم اول دعني وضح مساله نحن لسنا معارضه
لقيس سعيد نحن مقاومه لقيسعيد نحن لا
نتصرف داخل منظومه شرعيه فيها حكم ومعارضه
نحن نتصرف مع مغتصب للسلطه لا نعتبره
رئيسا للجمهوريه ولا نعتبره رئيسا للدوله
نعتبره مجرد متصل للسلطه منقلب خان
الامانه التي كلف بها من طرف شعب في
انتخابات 2019 ثلاث ملايين صوت التي حصل
عليها قصص عيد ليست اصوات في الهواء وليست
ورقه وليست امضاء على شكل صك على بياض هي
صلاحيات اسندت لرئيس الجمهوريه على اساس
عقد سياسي وعقد قانوني ودستوري هو الدستور
البلاد قيس سعيد انقذ والتهمه دستور
البلاد وخان الامانه التي كلف بها من طرف
التونسيون وفقد بذلك منذ 25 جنيه وهذا ما
كنا في مواطنون ضد الانقلاب من البدايه
بس بعد هذه الانتخابات يوم الغد ال بعد
هذه الانتخابات هي تاكيد على ان قيس سعيد
فقد شرعيته الان البلاد امام مفترق بين
خيارات قيس سعيد الاقليه التي صارت خيارات
اقليه وبين خيارات اخرى للشعب التونسي
هناك مجال همم لنزع فتيل هذه الازمه وعوده
المسار الديمقراطي للبلاد
فقط لان الوقت ده يهمنا
جمله واحده هي الذهاب الان الى انتخابات
رئاسيه مبكرا نحكم فيها الشعب بين هذين
الخيارين
قيصر سؤالي مواجهه سيد قيصر فيما يتعلق
بهذا الوضع الاقتصادي الرهن وقد اشرت له
في تفسير نسبه المشاركه وفي ظل هذا
التاجيل للمفاوضات مع صندوق النقد الدولي
بالتالي ماذا عن هذا الرجل الاقتصادي في
تونس في ظل هذا الوضع السياسي باختصار
وتكرنت
الوضع الاقتصادي في تونس بطبيعه لحال سيدي
هو
رهين توافقات جديده بين صندوق النقد
الدولي والحكومه التونسيه وصندوق النقد
الدولي كما تعلمون 16% منه تشكله الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يعني تقريبا لها اكثر
من خمس الاصوات والان الاشكال فقط
التونسيين مكثف عن المشاركه فيها سيكون له
تداعيات اقتصاديه واجتماعيه وتداعيات على
مستوى العلاقات الدوليه هناك همم
انفضحت سلطه الانقلاب بانها ليست مدعومه
شعبيه وهذا سيكون له كبير على علاقاتها
سوف
الدوليين شكرا
من تونس وكذلك الضيف من تونس ايضا الصباح
عفوا المحامي والباء والباحث في القانون
شكرا جزيلا لكم
[موسيقى]